hi guys i'm anirban from simply learn
and today
i will be giving you a tutorial on one
of the most talked about topics in the
world
of technology and that is machine
learning
so to start off with let's have a look
at the agenda
first we look into a life without
machine learning
then we'll move into a life with machine
learning
then we'll try to understand what is
machine learning actually
then we look into the types of machine
learning we'll talk about the right
machine learning solutions
then we'll move into the different
algorithms that machine learning has
finally we'll do a use case wherein
we'll be predicting the price of a house
using linear regression
let's talk about a life without machine
learning
for someone who doesn't know anything
about machine learning or artificial
intelligence
he or she might think that it is only
being used in robots or machines and
stuff
which is actually true as portrayed by
most of the sci-fi movies nowadays
but you wouldn't believe how much more
machine learning is giving us
how much of it we are using in our daily
lives let's say
you need information on any random topic
say a computer
the first place you would check would
definitely be google right
it would collect all the information on
the word you search for
and present it to you according to
relevance if there was no google
you would have to do it in a very hard
way that is by going through tens or
hundreds of books and articles
even after which you won't find the
answer
if we go back four to five years facial
recognition would be a thing
only showed in movies like mission
impossible or terminator or any of the
sci-fi movies you pick
but machine learning has made it
possible for facebook and instagram
to use this feature for your benefits
you don't have to go through the trouble
of tagging every single person present
in a picture that you have posted
facebook will automatically recognize
the people in the photo and tag them for
you
that saves a lot of time for you doesn't
it also
siri cortana iris all of them would not
be there to help you if there was no
machine learning
now that we know life would be a lot
more difficult without machine learning
let's look into the things that are run
by machine learning and we are using
them on our daily basis
let's enter the world of gaming ps4s and
xboxes
have introduced virtual reality glasses
which brings a whole new level of detail
into gaming
every time your head moves in real world
it replicates the movement in the
virtual world providing an excellent
gaming experience
then there is gesture control gaming
where in machine learning tracks your
body movement and makes a corresponding
movement in the game
finally in the game fifa your opponent
tends to adapt based on the kind of
strategy or gameplay you follow
that is again done by machine learning
i'm sure you must have shopped a lot
from amazon so let's look into some of
the places amazon makes user machine
learning
let's say you buy a formal t-shirt on
amazon
now as you buy it it suggests you formal
shoes
ties blazers and apparels that go with
what you have bought
that's the recommendation system powered
by machine learning again
the price on every product that you see
on amazon is varying every moment
based on demand that's being done by
machine learning algorithms
then comes customer segmentation
customer segmentation
is one of the most crucial thing for all
the e-commerce platforms
machine learning helps them
differentiate between customers based on
what they buy
how frequent are they and their reviews
this helps the companies to make sure
that their customers are taken care of
and the needs are being fulfilled
now let's talk about an app that you use
on a daily basis to reach office on time
yes it's uber caps once you have
traveled with uber
you must have noticed that it suggests
you the places you might want to go
based on your previous journeys
when you are taking a share how does the
app make sure that the cab you get is
travelled by the same route
you want to travel in there are so many
factors like the distance the traffic
the ratings
all of it is taken care of by machine
learning
for the past five minutes we have been
talking about how machine learning is
improving our lives
where all it is being used i have
probably said machine learning 100 times
already
i think it's about time that i tell you
what machine learning actually is
let's take an ordinary system that you
currently are using
it can't do much except from the basic
operations that you already know about
now let's add artificial intelligence or
for a layman's point of view
let's give the same machine the power to
think on its own
that is what machine learning basically
is it's an application of artificial
intelligence that provides systems
the ability to learn on their own and
improve from experience without being
programmed externally so if your
computer had machine learning
may be able to play the difficult parts
of a game for you or probably solve a
complicated mathematical equation for
you
that could be really helpful let's dive
in a little deeper and see how machine
learning works
let's say you provide a system with the
input data that carries the photos of
various kinds of fruits
now you want the system to figure out
what are the different fruits and group
them accordingly
so what the system does it analyzes the
input data
then it tries to find patterns patterns
like
shapes size and color
based on these patterns the system will
try to predict the different types of
fruit and segregate them
finally it keeps track of all such
decisions it took
in the process to make sure it's
learning the next time you ask the same
system to predict and segregate
the different types of fruits it won't
have to go through the entire process
again
that's how machine learning works now
let's look into the
types of machine learning machine
learning is primarily of three types
first one is supervised machine learning
as the name suggests
you have to supervise your machine
learning while you train it to work on
its own
it requires labeled training data next
up
is unsupervised learning wherein there
will be training data but
it won't be labeled finally
there's reinforcement learning wherein
the system learns on its own
let's talk about all these types in
detail let's try to understand how
supervised learning works
look at the pictures very very carefully
the monitor depicts the model or the
system
that we are going to train this is how
the training is done
we provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of a fruit say an
apple
then we provide another data set which
lets the model know
that these pictures were that of a fruit
called apple
this ends the training phase now what we
will do
is we provide a new set of data which
only contains pictures of apple
now here comes the fun part the system
can actually tell you
what fruit it is and it will remember
this and apply this knowledge in future
as well
that's how supervised learning works you
are training the model
to do a certain kind of an operation on
its own this kind of a model is
generally used into filtering spam mails
from your email accounts as well
yes surprise aren't you so let's move on
to unsupervised learning now
let's say we have a data set which is
cluttered in this case
we have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed this data
to the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it
in the end it categorizes the photos
into three types as you can see in the
image based on their similarities
so you provide the data to the system
and let the system do the rest of the
work
simple isn't it this kind of a model is
used by flipkart
to figure out the products that are well
suited for you
honestly speaking this is my favorite
type of machine learning out of all the
three
and this type has been widely shown in
most of the sci-fi movies lately
let's find out how it works imagine a
newborn baby
you put a burning candle in front of the
baby the baby does not know that if it
touches the flame its fingers might get
burned
so it does that anyway and gets hurt the
next time you put that candle in front
of the baby
it will remember what happened the last
time and would not repeat what it did
that's exactly how reinforcement
learning works
we provide the machine with a data set
wherein we ask it to identify
a particular kind of a fruit in this
case an apple
so what it does as a response it tells
us that it's a mango
but as we all know it's a completely
wrong answer so as a feedback we tell
the system
that it's wrong it's not a mango it's an
apple
what it does it learns from the feedback
and keeps that in mind
when the next time when we ask a same
question it gives us
the right answer it is able to tell us
that it's actually an apple
that is a reinforced response so that's
how reinforcement learning works
it learns from its mistakes and
experiences this model is used in games
like prince of persia or assassin's
creed or fifa
wherein the level of difficulty
increases as you get better with the
games
just to make it more clear for you let's
look at a comparison between supervised
and unsupervised learning
firstly the data involved in case of
supervised learning is labeled
as we mentioned in the examples
previously
we provide the system with a photo of an
apple and let the system know that this
is actually an apple
that is called label data so the system
learns from the label data and makes
future predictions
now unsupervised learning does not
require any kind of label data
because its work is to look for patterns
in the input data
and organize it the next point
is that you get a feedback in case of
supervised learning
that is once you get the output the
system tends to remember that and uses
it for the next operation
that does not happen for unsupervised
learning and the last point
is that supervised learning is mostly
used to predict data whereas
unsupervised learning
is used to find out hidden patterns or
structures in data
i think this would have made a lot of
things clear for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning
now let's talk about a question that
everyone needs to answer before building
a machine learning model
what kind of a machine learning solution
should we use
yes you should be very careful with
selecting the right kind of solution for
your model
because if you don't you might end up
losing a lot of time
energy and processing cost i won't be
naming the actual solutions because you
guys aren't familiar with them yet
so we will be looking at it based on
supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning so let's look
into the factors that might help us
select the right kind of machine
learning
solution first factor is the problem
statement describes the kind of model
you will be building
or as the name suggests it tells you
what the problem
is for example let's say the problem is
to predict the future stock market
prices
so for anyone who is new to machine
learning would have trouble figuring out
the right solution
but with time and practice you will
understand that for a problem statement
like this
solution based on supervised learning
would work the best for obvious
reasons then comes the size quality
and nature of the data if the data is
cluttered
you go for unsupervised if the data is
very large and categorical
we normally go for supervised learning
solutions
finally we choose the solution based on
their complexity
as for the problem statement wherein we
predict the stock market prices
it can also be solved by using
reinforcement learning
but that would be very very difficult
and time consuming unlike
supervised learning algorithms are not
types of machine learning
in the most simplest language they are
methods of solving a particular problem
so the first kind of method is
classification which falls under
supervised learning
classification is used when the output
you are looking for is a yes
or no or in the form a or b
or true or false like if a shopkeeper
wants to predict if a particular
customer will come back to his shop or
not
he will use a classification algorithm
the algorithms that fall under
classification
are decision tree knife base random
forest
logistic regression and knn
the next kind is regression this kind of
a method is used
when the predicted data is numerical in
nature
like if the shopkeeper wants to predict
the price of a product based on its
demand
it would go for regression the last
method is clustering
clustering is a kind of unsupervised
learning again it is used
when the data needs to be organized most
of the recommendation system used by
flipkart
amazon etc make use of clustering
another major application of it is in
search engines
the search engines study your old search
history to figure out
your preferences and provide you the
best search results
one of the algorithms that fall under
clustering is
k-means now that we know the various
algorithms
let's look into four key algorithms that
are used widely
we will understand them with very simple
examples
the four algorithms that we will try to
understand
are k nearest neighbor linear regression
decision tree and naive bayes
let's start with our first machine
learning solution k nearest neighbor
k nearest neighbor is again a kind of a
classification algorithm
as you can see on the screen the similar
data points form clusters
the blue one the red one
and the green one there are three
different clusters
now if we get a new and unknown data
point it is classified
based on the cluster closest to it or
the most similar to it
k in n is the number of nearest
neighboring data points we wish to
compare the unknown data with
let's make it clear with an example
let's say we have three clusters in a
cost to durability graph
first cluster is of footballs
the second one is of tennis balls
and the third one is of basketballs
from the graph we can say that the cost
of
footballs is high and the durability is
less the cost of
tennis balls is very less but the
durability is high
and the cost of basketballs is as high
as the durability
now let's say we have an unknown data
point we have a black spot
which can be one kind of the balls but
we don't know what kind it is
so what we'll do we'll try to classify
this using knn
so if we take k is equal to 5 we draw a
circle keeping the unknown data point in
the center
and we make sure that we have five balls
inside
that circle in this case we have a
football
a basketball and three tennis balls now
since we have the highest number of
tennis balls inside the circle
the classified ball would be a tennis
ball
so that's how k nearest neighbor
classification is done
linear regression is again a type of
supervised learning algorithm
this algorithm is used to establish
linear relationship between variables
one of which would be dependent and the
other one would be independent
like if we want to predict the weight of
a person based on his height
weight would be the dependent variable
and height would be independent
let's have a look at it through an
example
let's say we have a graph here showing a
relationship between height
and weight of a person let's put the y
axis as
h and the x-axis
as weight
so the green dots are the various data
points
these green dots are the data points and
d
is the mean squared error that is the
perpendicular distances
from the line to the data points are the
error values
this error tells us how much the
predicted values vary from the original
value
let's ignore this blue line for a while
so let's say if this is our regression
line
you can see the distance from all the
data points from this line
is very high so if we take
this line as a regression line the error
in the prediction
will be too high so
in this case the model will not be able
to give us a good prediction
let's say we draw another regression
line here like this
even in this case you can see that the
perpendicular distance of the data
points from the line
is very high so the error value will
still come as high as the last one
so this model will also not be able to
give us a good prediction
so what to do so finally we draw a line
which is this blue line so here we can
see that the distance
of the data points from the line is very
less
relative to the other two lines we drew
so the value of d for this line will be
very less
so in this case if we take any value on
the x-axis the corresponding value on
the y-axis will be our prediction
and given the fact that the d is very
low our prediction should be good also
this is how regression works we draw a
line a regression line that is in such a
way
that the value of d is the least
eventually giving us good predictions
this algorithm that is decision tree is
a kind of an algorithm you can very
strongly
relate to it uses a kind of a branching
method to realize the problem and make
decisions based on the conditions
let's take this graph as an example
imagine yourself sitting at home getting
bored
you feel like going for a swim what you
do is you check if it's sunny outside so
that's your first condition
if the answer to that condition is yes
you go for a swim
if it's not sunny then the next question
you would ask yourself is if it's
raining outside so that's condition
number two
if it's actually raining you cancel the
plan and stay indoors
if it's not raining then you would
probably go outside
and have a walk so that's the final node
that's how decision tree algorithm works
you probably use this every day
it realizes a problem and then takes the
decisions based on the answers to every
conditions
nybis algorithm is mostly used in cases
where a prediction needs to be done on a
very large dataset
it makes use of conditional probability
conditional probability is the
probability of an event say a
happening given that another event b has
already happened
this algorithm is most commonly used in
filtering spam mails in your email
account
let's say you receive a mail the model
goes through your old spam mail records
then it uses space theorem to predict if
the present mail
is a spam mail or not so pc of a
is the probability of even c occurring
when a has already occurred
b a of c is the probability of event a
occurring when c has already occurred
and b c is the probability of event c
occurring and p a is a probability of
event a
occurring let's try to understand naive
bayes with a better example
nybase can be used to determine on which
days to play cricket
based on the probabilities of a day
being rainy windy or sunny
the model tells us if a match is
possible
if we consider all the weather
conditions to be event a for us
and the probability of a match being
possible even c
so the model applies the probabilities
of event a and c
into the base theorem and predicts if a
game of cricket is possible on a
particular day or not
in this case if the probability of c of
a
is more than 0.5 we can be able to play
a game of cricket
if it's less than 0.5 we won't be able
to do that
that's how naive bass algorithm works
now we have reached the most important
part of our video the use case
wherein we'll be predicting the price of
a house using machine learning
look at this guy he seems a bit worried
doesn't he
let's figure out what the problem here
is so
is planning on selling his house in a
few months
but he's unable to decide what price he
should sell it for
so let's help him predict the price of
his house using machine learning
so our problem statement is to predict
the price of a house
using machine learning that will be
implemented on python
now the first job at hand is to figure
out which algorithm to use here
we will be using linear regression for
this problem as i mentioned before
linear regression is a kind of a
supervised learning
let's have a look at the reason why we
are choosing linear regression over all
the other algorithms
so the first reason here is the output
is quantitative in nature and directly
proportional to the variables
so i've mentioned this before many many
times that if the prediction is
quantitative in nature
linear regression is the best choice the
next reason
is low computation cost what does it
mean
if you use an algorithm that involves a
lot of equation solving and stuff
you'll need a very powerful system so
that will cost you more
but not in the case of linear regression
because it is a very simple algorithm
and it can be done in any normal system
finally linear regression
is easy to understand as i mentioned
before
let's have a look at the various
features in the data set
the first feature is the lower status of
population in that area
then comes the mean price of all the
houses in their area
then the building age the tax rate the
average number of rooms in every houses
the distance to five boston employments
accessibility
to highways and finally the per capita
crime rate
so these all are the factors that we'll
be taking into consideration to predict
the price of a house
let's move ahead so let's quickly try to
understand how linear regression works
so this is your model the computer here
and you provide the training data
all the values for the different
features you provide the system
so that it can learn from it as you can
see it is trying to study the training
data
it learns from it and then you give it
the test data you give it some values
that it needs to predict
from the training data that it learned
it will be able to predict the price of
the house that's how the entire model
works
it's simple right now that we understand
what we are supposed to do
let's implement the entire model on
python we will be using jupiter notebook
to run the code
it's because it will be easier for you
to understand and i'll be able to
explain every line of it to you properly
we'll be using scikit-learn to load all
the data and libraries
psychic learn is a library specially
dedicated to machine learning in case
you are programming on python so let's
start off by importing the required
libraries for the model
so let's import the various libraries
from scikit learn
firstly comes up numpy numpy is a
support for large arrays and matrices
that we are going to use in this
use case then comes pandas pandas is a
package
that makes working with relational data
easier then
from the regression model that we are
going to use
to check the accuracy of the model we
import
train test split from scalar dot cross
validation import
train test
split so that's it
all the important libraries have been
imported
let's move on now to run the cell
we press shift plus enter so that's it
the cell is running properly now from
scikit learn again
we load the data set and to load that
the code is from
sklearn dot data sets
import load boston
sling is boston equal to load
so it makes it easier for us to load the
entire data set
if we want so again pressing shift and
enter to run the cell
no errors so now we'll try to have a
look at the data set
boston so as you can see
the entire data set is available in
front of us
this is the entire data set this are the
values of all the features
that we have these are the names
of the features that we talked about
before
and these are the target values with
this value
we will compare the predictions that we
have
so now we'll divide the data into two
different data frames
this is how we create a data frame dfx
this is one of the data frame equal to
pd
so here's where the pandas library
coming to work
person.data
columns equal to boston
our features feature names
so the next data frame would be
dfy
to frame
boston dot target
so in this fit data frame all the target
values will be loaded
so that's it we run the cell too it's
running fine
now let's try to describe the data
that is our dfx
dot describe now you can see that this
table
provides us with the count of every
features the mean value for every
feature
and the standard deviation so all these
data can be useful but not in this case
so let's not waste time here
so next comes an important part here we
will apply regression now
so the code is rag equal to linear
model dot linear regression so that's
why we loaded this library in the
beginning
we press shift plus enter the cell is
running pretty well
no errors now we split our data into
train and test data
to validate the model as we move ahead i
will show you how to do it as well
the code is x
train comma
x test comma
y train
comma y test
equal to train
test split t
f x comma d f
y test
size test size is equal to 0.2 so that
means
20 percent of the data is test and the
remaining is trained
so random state is needed when we are to
run and validate our
model multiple times so in this case we
put it is equal to four
so now what we do is we fit the data set
into the regression function
the code is reg
dot fit x
train y
train shift and enter and now as we can
see
that our data set is fit
into the function that we call before
line 14. you can see that so next
let's check the coefficient so the code
is
reg dot qf
so these are the weights and these are
optimal
so let me tell you what coefficient
actually is
so the coefficients give us an idea of
how much the dependent variable
will increase if the independent
variable value increases by 1.
if you take the equation of a line let's
say the regression line
that is y equal to mx plus c so c is the
constant
and m is the coefficient in this case
very simple ok now
we will predict the prices so a will be
the predicted price so a
equal to reg dot predict
x test so we will be predicting the
prices
according to arrays okay
so a in brackets will
specify the array number so in this case
we give three
as we press enter we get array
equal to 18.15 so for array three
we are getting 18.1 so if we check on
the test data what is
the value for array number three this is
array number zero this is one
2 3 for array 3 the test data is 19.3
and we are getting 18.1 so that's the
prediction so you can see that the
predicted value and the original value
don't vary much the predictions are
pretty good
so now let's test for array number five
so in the test table
that is zero one two three four
five so in the test the value
for the fifth array is 24.5 and we are
getting
25.4 so the prediction
is still pretty good so our model is
functioning pretty well
now let's try and find the error
so the code will be np dot mean
in bracket a minus
y test so a is the predicted value and y
test is the test value
this gives us the error now if we square
this value we get
the mean squared error
press shift and enter so the error value
is 25
so that's our mean squared error so we
have successfully created a linear
regression model
now the error value that we got is 25
which is good enough as you have seen in
the predictions
it can be made better by manipulating
the data as well
lesser the mean squared error better the
predictions
so let me go through the entire process
once more for your convenience
firstly we'll be importing the various
libraries from scikit-learn
then we load the boston dataset from
scikit learn again
then we transfer the data into two
different data frames
so if we describe the boston data set we
get a table like this wherein we get the
count
mean value and standard deviation for
every feature
then we train the regression model next
up we split the data into test and train
wherein the test size is 0.2 and the
random state is equal to 4.
then we fit the data into the regression
model after that
we calculate the coefficients and the
value of the coefficients
you can see on the screen so then we try
to predict the prices
so for array number 2 we get a value
17.5
and for the same array on the test data
it is 17.4 so the
difference between the predicted data
and the original data is very less
a model was functioning pretty well for
array number three
we get 18.1 and on the test data it is
19.3
so finally we calculate the mean square
error
which came out to be 25.4 which is quite
good for our model
so that brings us to the end of the
video i hope you guys understood the
concepts
put your doubts and feedbacks in the
comments below and stay tuned for more
videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here